aujourd'hui c'est le jour que tu peux
enfin vous parlez du one + 7 pro que
j'utilise depuis quelques jours je
trouve que c'est vraiment un très bon
smartphone
parce qu'il raconte vraiment une
histoire cette histoire c'est quoi c'est
l'histoire d'une marque s'appelle one
plus one placez-vous vraie relance tout
ça à l'américaine wyplosz qui
smartphones après smartphone fabrique
des flagships killer des smartphones
haut de gamme ea perspect et hyper
résistant qui viennent concurrencer les
smartphones et plus premium le plus haut
de gamme à un tarif vraiment défiant
toute concurrence mais cette année ils
ont essayé de faire la même chose mais
un peu différemment vous avez donc deux
smartphones le one piece est éloigne
plus c'est trop alors aujourd'hui on va
se concentrer sur le one + 7 pro je vous
parlerai du wan plus est un peu plus
tard mais il va devoir très très très
très rapidement et souvent de plus celle
propre
il vient raconter une nouvelle histoire
dans l'histoire de la marque et qui vaut
vraiment intéressante c'est à dire le
smartphone plus payer plus
professionnelle qui va encore au delà
qui va encore plus loin que ce qu'on
pouvait retrouver avant dans la marque
et qui vient vraiment dit regretter
titiller huawei sur son eau pétrole pro
par exemple ou alors samsung sur son
galaxy s 10 voire s10 plus et c'est
vraiment ça l'histoire nous raconte ce
smartphone et propose des choses qui
sont juste hallucinante d'un point de
vue purement technologique et vous allez
voir les usa ce qui en découle
c'est vraiment dingue
[Musique]
avec le one piece est trop en plus
dragué une cible toujours plus exigeants
qui est toujours plus flagship killer et
voyez ce qui fait vraiment la
particularité de smartphones c'est que
vous n'avez plus du tout dans koch vous
avez un très grand écran et ça c'est
vraiment bien parce que ça apporte
encore plus d'immersion que vous avez
des nouvelles couleurs ça c'est la
nebula bleus que je trouve
personnellement juste magnifique
ce dégradé bleu plus foncé bleu plus
clair est vraiment bien alors vous avez
également le meilleur engrais vous avez
aussi une couleur amende mais en tout
cas moi celle là c'est vraiment ça que
je trouve la plus jolie ans j'aime bien
la couleur noire aussi mais ça que c'est
nouveau ça apporte quelque chose de tout
nouveau dans la masse est vraiment
vraiment bien vous retrouver sur les
côtés toujours le bouton aussi pour
venir à qu'il est votre silencieux mode
vibreur et compagnie le bouton pour
l'allumer pour l'éteindre vous avez ici
un haut parleur qui situe la deûle usb
type celle-ci double lecteur de carte
sim playmate de kaffrine soit c'est
vachement bien sûr le côté ici le bouton
de volume vous retrouver sur l'eau votre
petite caméra pop up qui vient se lever
un micro pour la réduction bout qui
achète juste là le 2ème micro est cachée
justice y est vous avez votre trip
caméra je vous explique tout à l'heure
un peu tout ce qu'on peut faire avec
tout ce qui au niveau spécifications
techniques et c'est un smartphone avec
du corning gorilla glass cinq mois la
première chose qui m'a frappé c'est
capteur d'empreintes digitales vous avez
un capteur d'empreintes digitales
optique qui est intégré à l'écran on
avait déjà l'année dernière soit le one
+ 6 tc vrai que les capteurs m'emprunte
digitaux petit je suis pas hyper hyper
fan parce que je trouve qu'ils vont un
peu moins vite
normalement en tout cas que lecteur
d'empreintes digitales ultrasonique sauf
que là c'est pas du tout le cas
vous posez à peine votre doigt dessus ça
déverrouille tout de suite c'est
vraiment génial regarde et hop je prends
je pose le doigt dessus ça déverrouille
immédiatement c'est vraiment une super
belle avance et ça ça vient vraiment
montré tout le boulot café one plus
dessus c'est vraiment génial regardez
c'est ouf enfin vous venez vous poser
juste votre doigt dessus ça des verrous
c'est extrêmement rapide ça c'est
vraiment top autre point qui est
vraiment géniale sur ce smartphone c'est
son grand écran vous avez un écran
amoled avec une diagonale de 6,67 pouces
avec une résolution qhd plus vous avez
dû 3120 pixels par 1440 pixels vous avez
vraiment une super belle définition à
516 pixels par pouce ratio 19.5 ne
vienne c'est tout simplement d'écran qui
est vachement bien et en plus vous avez
un taux de rafraîchissement de 90 m
alors je sais pas si c'est un truc qui
vous parle trop mais c'est vraiment
génial
vous pouvez régler si vous souhaitez on
est fâché
si vous voulez gagner un peu en
autonomie avec une plus petite
résolution vous pouvez le faire par
défaut il est en commutation automatique
moi je les ai mis directement en cuir
des plus ça va pomper légèrement mais
par contre je vraiment avoir la
meilleure résolution et vous avez
également la fréquence d'actualisation
c'est à dire 90 heures vous aurez une
fluidité qui est maximale quelque chose
qui est vraiment bien notamment pour le
gaming pareil vous allez gagner un petit
peu l'autonomie si vous allez sur du 60
hertz est pour moi un smartphone comme
ça faut vraiment profiter de
l'expérience 90 hercules hd plus c'est
vraiment génial
après il ya plein de petites options au
niveau de l'affichage me sort va le
regarder après lorsqu'on arrive sur vous
et vous allez voir c'est vraiment
vraiment bien moyen truc qui m'a frappé
avec ce smartphone quand j'ai commencé à
l'utiliser
la première nuit c'est la luminosité je
n'avais pas demi en luminosité
adaptative j'avais poussé à fond et
lorsque j'allume le smartphone la nuit
ça n'est clair la pièce c'est juste
hallucinant ce n'est pas une lampe de
chevet c'est pas non plus un plafonnier
mais c'est vrai qu'il est extrêmement
lumineux c'est vraiment agréable alors
attention ce n'est pas la luminosité à
fond parce qu'à un moment masculin
gaspésie donc m'étais vraiment une
luminosité adaptative en fonction de
l'éclairage
mais c'est vrai que le smartphone est
vraiment lumineux sassou sy un pack est
très positif
trop de poids qui est vraiment super
sont les haut parleurs stéréo vous avez
un haut parleur qui situent juste là en
bas et vous avez un haut parleur qui est
caché là qui est très large qui est
juste là ça vous apporte vraiment un
côté plus immersif
lorsque vous le tenez comme ça que vous
allez jouer à des jeux ou alors lorsque
vous allez regarder des vidéos sa porte
vraiment en immersion l'expérience audio
est vraiment génial expérience vidéo est
vraiment grave alors après ça dépend
directement de votre connexion internet
si vous avez une excellente connaissance
tout de suite ça va aller beaucoup vais
la regarder la leçon est poussée à fond
j'ai un souk aient vraiment bien j'ai un
spectre assez large je récupère quand
même guidera pour venger les petits haut
parleurs pour moi c'est vraiment des
chevaux dit le fait d'avoir une audio
l'a aidé au delà ça rapporte en
immersion
le fait de bavardant koch profite
vraiment d'un grand écran ce qu'elle te
regarder la vidéo c'est hyper
appréciable et rien que pour ça j'adore
ce smartphone
côté performances on a aussi ce qui se
fait mieux on a un qualcomm snapdragon
855 c'est le dernier soc de qualcomm
dégradée en 7 nanomètres on a soit 6
giga de ram soit 8 gigas de ram soit 12
un drame si vous cherchez vraiment de la
fluidité vous pouvez y aller 12 giga de
ram c'est énorme
et en termes de stockage avait deux
configurations possibles soit 128 giga
de stockage soit 256 giga de stockage
ufs 3.0 c'est extrêmement pratique ça va
vite c'est un smartphone qui est très
rapide continue à toujours vous savez
sur son idée de flagship qui leur
larguait en termes de performances très
clairement et je vous le dis tout cela
couplé avec un écran en 90 ans avec une
résolution qhd plus pur du gaming
typiquement thibout jouer un pib j'ai si
vous jouez un asphalte 9
vous avez vraiment de la sensation c'est
vraiment gêné alors je vais vous
expliquer parce que vous avez aussi un
mode jeu qui s'appelle le fnatic mode
ce mode là vient vraiment optimiser
votre bécane pour le jeu vous avez un
retour haptique lorsque vous jouez c'est
vraiment bien vous avez une rame qui est
boosté vous allez pouvoir décider si
vous voulez être dérangé par des appels
oui non quoi commence sur peux vous
appeler
si on vous appelle c'est directement sur
les haut-parleurs pour vous ne sortiez
pas de votre jour ya pas mal d'options
qui sont vraiment bien et surtout ce qui
est vraiment intéressant c'est que vous
avez un refroidissement liquide à
l'intérieur ce qui fait que votre
machine et chauffe pas vous voyez aller
pouvait jouer pendant des heures jeudi
des heurts bond aux amants vous avez
vous flingue un peu les jeunes vont se
régaler un peu vos lomé vous pouvez
jouer sans problème par exemple un pib
ou je vous dis asphalte neuf ou ce que
vous voulez y a pas de souci c'est un
smartphone qui va être endurant qui va
être performant qui ne chauffe pas et
qui pour cela est vraiment agréable
regardez là je montre fnatic mode
optimisé pour le cpu optimisé pour le
gpu optimisés pour la mémoire après j'ai
d'autres paramètres
j'ai effectivement active est ici mon
retour haptique j'ai activé
l'amélioration de l'affichage je peux
répondre aux appels via l'eau par un bon
moi j'ai pas envie d'être dérangé une
notification vous appelle tierces peut
bloquer l'écran suivant fin je peux
faire pas mal de choses il ya plein de
paramètres up paf
j'active c'est vraiment génial j'ai une
machine qui complètement optimisé pour
venir jouer à mes jeux la voix soit une
petite partie de pbg vous allez voir
c'est vraiment toi regardez c'est
vraiment hyper appréciable lorsque vous
jouez publie déjà vous avez pas
d'encoches vous profiter vraiment d'un
grand écran regardez ça c'est
extrêmement fluide l'expérience elle est
vraiment top le fait d'avoir du
rafraîchissement 90 heures c'est
vraiment hyper fluide c'est super smooth
c'est la même chose sur un jeu comme un
club d'aller profiter d'une qualité
audio qui est complètement immersif qui
est vraiment génial l'expérience de
guémy
vraiment intéressante pour moi c'est une
super réussite là dessus de la part de
votre place l'expérience multimédia pour
de la vidéo pour du gaming on a tout ce
qu'il faut en terme de performances
d'affichage de différents modes logiciel
c'est vraiment bien il faut dire
d'ailleurs en plus vous avez au niveau
graphique une adreno 640 ça marche aussi
parfaitement bien et puisque je vous
parle de multimédia vous avez du son qui
est compatible dolby et moscou allaient
pouvoir ni réglée dynamique films
musique comme vous voulez ça c'est à
vous de voir pour les réglages que vous
l'avoir vous avez aussi un mode
écouteurs d'ailleurs les écouteurs on va
reparler très prochainement avec les
nouveaux one pluzz belette ce wireless
deux en or pâle avant ses tests d'ici
quelques jours dont vous invite bien
évidemment vous abonner pour tout savoir
[ __ ] en tant que je pourrais
éventuellement venir lui reprocher c'est
que je trouve un petit peu lourd alors
après il ya plein de techno et harrier
vous avez un superbe écran donc bon tout
ça justifie mais il fait quand même
c'est 206 g
c'est vrai que c'est pas le smartphone
le plus léger que je connaisse à côté de
ça il a tellement point positif ça nous
fait rapidement oublier cette 206 g la
grosse question qui se pose maintenant
c'est qu'en est-il de l'autonomie
puisque vous avez un écran qui est très
lumineux vous avez un écran avec une
grosse définition vous n'avez de la
performance derrière vous avez une
machine qui est sûr booster qu'en est-il
de l'autonomie est ce que ce smartphone
tiens oui non pas comment aviez vous
savez vous allez peut-être être surpris
vous avez une grosse batterie de 4000
milliards erreur à l'intérieur cette
bécane et ce qui est assez bluffant
c'est la longévité en fonction de vous
en fonction de paramètres que vous allez
faire en fonction du fait que vous allez
être qu un des plus hauts alors vous
allez descendre en flèche des plus si
vous êtes sur un taux de
rafraîchissement à 90 ans soit 60 perse
en fonction des de ce que vous allez
faire si vous allez jouer tout ça ça va
forcément modifié l'autonomie des de ce
smartphone mais c'est un smartphone que
vous pouvez garder un jour et demi deux
jours sans aucun problème en étant au
top des performances si vous passez en
mode un peu plus économies d'énergie
pour finir intérêts germes en plus en
tout cas parce que ça nous montre ce qui
est vraiment intéressant c'est le savoir
faire qui est maîtrisé d'ailleurs je pas
si vous savez mais le qualcomm c'est un
dragon 855 a vraiment apporter un mieux
en terme d'autonomie
le fait d'avoir par exemple un écran
amoled dessus c'est vraiment bien parce
que ça vous permet aussi d'économiser
notamment si vous passez en mode nuit
parce qu'un pixel noir d'un pixel est un
donc vous avez une bécane qui est sûre
optimisé pour toutes les utilisations et
pour tous les cas d'usagés mais qui
également sur optimisé pour l'autonomie
mais en plus de ça si vous arrivez à un
moment où vitam hamas gelée par charge
et paf attention vous lever le matin
bien vous prenez vous branchez vous
laisser une petite
meyer vous êtes à 75% vous êtes
quasiment à 100% les 100% vous les avez
en moins d'une heure c'est un smartphone
qui surchargent extrêmement vite grâce à
la vram charge c'est vraiment
hallucinant par contre ce qu'on pourrait
lui reprocher éventuellement c'est qu'il
ya pas de recharge sans fil dans
l'absolu et point positif la recharge
sans fil ça ne dérange pas trop surtout
vu le positionnement tarifaire mais ça
je vous en parle dans quelques instants
et en plus de ça vous intéresse l
accessoire qui est sympa c'est le wrap
charge vous avez de la recharge rapide
pour votre voiture c'est plutôt cool
comme ça des fois si vous partez en
voiture vous n'êtes pas pensé à le
charger comme ça ça pourrait vous sauver
la vie
parlons maintenant du pot qui vous
répond tout nouveau très intéressant
c'est l'appareil photo alors vous en
avez probablement entendu par led à
l'avant vous avez cette caméra pop up ça
c'est vraiment génial j'adore y ait un
côté un peu moins des toits légèrement
je trouve ça vraiment vraiment bien
parce que cette caméra pop up on n'a pas
une station oddo maintient cet
accessoire qui est un peu fragile je
peux l'abîmé non non on a vraiment
sensation de robustesse voyez je tourne
je veux malle arrière elle rentrait le
sort silva son clan plus de vingt petit
effet la regarder devant
c'est vachement joly alors j'aime bien
je trouve que c'est une bonne idée en
tout cas ces bolides elle permet de
libérer de l'espace utile sur l'écran
d'avoir un très grand écran et pour moi
personnellement ça me pose absolument
aucun problème
one piece de la donne pour 300 mais
l'ouverture fermeture dont bon je pense
que vous avez temps de voir venir ça
fait 150 ouvertures par jour ça pendant
cinq ans à mon avis vous êtes vraiment
tranquille en plus si vous voulez
l'utiliser pour déverrouiller vous
pouvez y sonne locke marche avec vous
avez absolument aucun problème savoir si
une caméra de 5 mégapixels qu'une
ouverture de f 2.0 vous pouvez faire de
la vidéo suit bien évidemment en 1080p à
30 images par seconde
après pour toutes les personnes qui
auraient peur de cette petite caméra
s'il fait tomber mon téléphone sans
risque de casse et bien écoutez
rassurez-vous parce que en cas de chute
se referme tout seul why hop je les fais
comme ça ça vient
schild détecter la caméra frontale a été
abaissée souhaitez vous utiliser à
nouveau les caméras frontales relevé la
caméra c'est magique ça marche c'est
super et ça s'est vraiment bien parce
que on dira si je la fais tomber je
pourrais la casse et infocentre comme
alto mais pas du tout hop là voyez c'est
vraiment vraiment cool et à l'arrière
vous avez bien évidemment un triple
module photo a commencé par une caméra
de 48 mégapixels c'est la caméra c'est
la sony mx 5 186 vous en ai déjà
beaucoup parler depuis le début de
l'année c'est une caméra qui permet
d'avoir notamment la technologie 4
pixels en main qui va être vraiment bien
pour des captures de nuit
vous avez en plus une ouverture là
dessus af 1.6 donc vraiment bien pour la
photo nuit je vous montrais ça dans
quelques instants
vous avez une deuxième caméra c'était
l'objectif de 8 mégapixels avec
l'ouverture de f 2.4 qui va voir une
stabilisation optique soit la caméra
principale vous allez voir une
stabilisation optique et électronique et
la troisième caméra c'est un ultra
grand-angle 217 degré 16 mégapixels qui
ouvre à 2.2 et vous avez dessus un zoom
optique x 3 est un jeu hybride x 10 du
point de vue logiciel est un super
boulot a été fait donc la voyez hop je
mets la gémoze une fois 3 donc là je
suis en zone complètement optique et
ensuite je peux venir arrivé que la
petite molette tout ça c'est vraiment
pratique parce que c'est hyper intuitif
et se fait jusqu'à mon zone hybride x 10
et c'est quand même plutôt pas malheur
vous savez moi et la stabilisation
ça vient de moi c'est pas terrible mais
par contre pour aller souhaiter plein de
sujets vous le montrer dans quelques
instants
c'est vraiment vraiment vraiment génial
et là vous avez l'ultra grand temps
qu'ils marchent aussi parfaitement
galant luttera grand temps pour faire un
petit peu gaffe
lorsque vous le tenez comme ça pas faire
glisser vos doigts donc prenez le
vraiment comme ça si vous le prenez
comme ça vous agace que d'avoir un petit
bout de doigts qui va dire forthac
l'objectif donc tout n'est vraiment
comme ça parce qu'il fait vraiment son
boulot c'est vraiment un très grand
angle sinon dans l'absolu ça marche bien
vous avez bien évidemment toute la
partie vidéo sur la caméra rien pour
filmer jusqu'à enquête qui aa soit rang
soit 60 images par seconde
vous pouvez faire du slow motion en
1080p à 240 images par seconde ou alors
en 720p à 480 images par seconde
mode vidéo mode photo le fameux mode
portrait bien évidemment mode paysage
nocturne et si vous voulez vous venez
chercher par là et là vous avez gratter
le mode professionnel mode accéléré
panorama ralenti et tous les paramètres
qui sont situées juste là les photos
elle-même se trouve vraiment vraiment de
bonne qualité las les prêts que
l'objectif principal fait le point
devant ça marche vachement bien je fais
le point derrière ça marche aussi
parfaitement bien en fonction de ce que
vous allez venir chercher a ajouté la
voyez avec le zoom jeu toujours notre
côté j'utilise la la le téléobjectif x
10 ça marche super bien là j'utilise mon
grand temps que ça marche aussi vraiment
bien ça s'est pris en photo avec elle la
caméra normale j'ai commencé à zoomer il
agit continuer sous espaly vachement
loin et lorsque j'utilise le grand temps
vous avez dit fait vachement attention à
vos doigts moi je m'en suis rendu compte
qu'après les petits bouts de bois qui
traîne son côté donc tunnel vraiment
comme ça lorsque vous faites des photos
avec un grand-angle fenêtres on arrive à
choper le drapeau anglais qui la faute
est tout en haut alors une fois de plus
là on est sur une photo standard la
qualité vous
bien avec le grand-angle a toujours avec
mon fameux petits bouts de doigts dont
faut quand même faire un petit peu gaffe
là dessus mais une fois qu'on l'a
compris voyez je les ai enlevés je me
suis rendu compte lui enlever ça marche
tout de suite hyper bien regarder je me
mets là je commence à venir vous mais en
suisse mais le zoom faut disent que je
vous propose c'est vous fait défiler
quelques photos ils vont dire est ce que
vous en pensez en banque
[Musique]
ok
[Applaudissements]
oui quand même
dubé
oui
[Musique]
charest
ouais
oui
m
[Musique]
là
m
d
tu m
de yuki
v
un petit bémol sur le mode nuit au
niveau du traitement logiciel
il ya des fois c'est vachement bien sûr
les lumières en bateau dans l'eau c'est
bien mais les traitements au niveau du
ciel c'est très très bizarre regarder la
télé c'est beaucoup de ciels on sait pas
si c'est la nuit si c'est le jour c'est
un peu bizarre
gardez là c'est pas avec ça c'est une
chose qui est prise en pleine nuit alors
le rendu est sympa c'est pas mal mais
des fois bon voilà c'est ça un petit peu
trop là je me croirait presque en plein
jour regarder le ciel on a l'impression
que le soleil en train de se coucher
voire carrément de se lever sauf que là
il est minuit c'est la nuit noire voilà
c'est un petit peu bizarre même chose là
dessus
à côté de ça le rendu est assez bluffant
lorsque je viens là lorsque je viens
chercher la voyez sur toute la partie de
ville c'est bien mais c'est vrai que sur
les parties un petit peu de de ciel tout
de suite ça c'est un peu bizarre c'était
les choses peuvent être corrigés d'un
point de vue logiciel après paroisse de
plus le mode portrait fonctionne aussi
très bien je suis passé chez dans les
meilleures conditions la regarder voyez
entre mes doigts
c'est hyper détour et la léger flou
léger ici au niveau de mon pull
mais sinon je veux ça fonctionne super
bien bon faut dire aussi que c'est un
dragon 855 pour ça il fait vraiment
vraiment bien le boulot la caméra elle
fit aussi fait relativement bien le
boulot les photos sont sont de bonne
qualité
ça fonctionne alors le meilleur vous
l'aurez bien évidemment que la caméra
arrière de 40 6 mégapixels mais pour
prendre des seule fille ça ira
parfaitement bien côté os vous tournez
sur oxygen os vous vous en douterez ici
c'est la version 9.5 points 2 qui tourne
bien évidemment sur un android 9 paille
pour moi que c'est jeanne ou s il est
toujours plus optimisée avec toujours
plus de fonctionnalités qui vont dans le
bon sens on sent vraiment intéressant
comme je vous le disais dans le mode
affichage pour venir régler s'il est le
mode nocturne les paramétrer pour qu'ils
se mettent automatiquement du coucher du
soleil
au lever du soleil pour moi c'est ce cas
mieux vaut venir selon l'acte iv si vous
le souhaitez ça venir modifier un peu la
température de votre écran casse un peu
la lumière bleue la voir plus clair plus
sombres je trouve que c'est vraiment
vraiment demandé glee jableh et bien
évidemment toute la question de la
navigation par jes que moi je fais hop
comme ça la question de bien-être
numérique pour savoir ce que vous avez
fait aujourd'hui de votre smartphone
comment vous l'avez utiliser ça peut
aussi être vraiment intéressant pour se
rendre compte de nos usages et puis des
fois décroché justement si vous voulez
décrocher vous avez un mode zen le
modèle il va vous permettre de venir
vraiment décrocher profiter vos animaux
de compagnie ok c'est bien profiter de
moments romantiques c'est pas mal ça
pourrait vous aurait été de votre couple
profitez de conversations intimes
téléphone posé pour profiter de la vie
vous activez le mode zen et là vous
pouvez plus utiliser vos smartphones
pendant 20 minutes juste passer des
appels d'urgence tout cas vous avez un
pépin ou alors
utilisez l'appareil photo si vous voyez
un truc que vraiment vous voulez
immortalisé voyez un truc qui m'a bluffé
lorsque j'ai voulu faire une photo j'ai
voulu photographier ce petit panneau là
tout de suite
il a reconnu l'url me l'a proposé ce
pouvez cliquer directement arrivé dessus
ça c'est vraiment génial voyez tout le
boulot qui fait derrière avec
l'intelligence artificielle c'est un
point de détail mais en terme d'usagé je
trouve ça vraiment vraiment intéressant
autre point intéressant vous avez une
aide de notification ce qu on pourrait
regretter c'est que c'est un smartphone
qui n'a pas de certification il n'est
pas certifié ip67 ou ip68 donc
potentiellement potentiellement pas
résistant à l'eau et à la poussière
potentiellement on a discuté avec one
plus nous ont confirmé que le smartphone
et eliane évidemment complètement
résistant à l'eau et à la poussière dès
lors que votre caméra pop-up été refermé
bien évidemment pour éviter que de l'eau
vient de rentrer ici bon dans l'absolu
vous risquez rien ils nous ont assuré
que le smartphone comme ça et est
étanche s'il rend compte de l'eau ça
passera parfaitement bien alors je vous
invite bien évidemment à ne pas le jeter
dans une piscine à ne pas user dans un
aquarium ans que vous ayez pour faire le
test
mais si ce n'est à pleuvoir si vous êtes
éclaboussé normalement ça devrait quand
même relativement bien se passer
il a bien évidemment du wifi vous vous
en douterez on a du bluetooth 5.0 on a
du nfc pour le paiement dématérialisé
c'est bien évidemment un smartphone que
je vous conseille très très très
fortement de venir protéger parce que
même si les travaux comme ça faudrait
pas l'abîmer
vous avez soit les cop domine plus qui
sont disponibles vous pouvez trouver sur
le site de greenpeace utiliser tous les
très bons aux revendeurs sympathique
soit sinon écopent de mon partenaire
rhinochill également alors là ce sont
des coques pour le one plus ce système
j'ai pas encore reçu les coques duo voix
de plus cette prompte néanmoins regarder
je vous montre enfin petit cadeau
sympathique la coque
monsieur grübel celle là je pense pas
vous puissiez la commander mais celle là
elle est pour moi elle est banale et
unique dont vous allez c'est coquelin
qui sont très sympa d'ailleurs si elle
vous intéresse ces coques de rhinochill
vous avez soit la coque soit le bumper
comme ça si vous voulez quand même
profiter du dos mais aussi une bonne
alternative
vous mettez votre smartphone en bon là
dedans je vais pas le faire parce que
c'est pas le bon ça vous permet d'avoir
de la visibilité sur le dos ça vous
intéresse bien évidemment que ce soit
pour le smartphone ou pour les coques
vous avez tous les liens en bas dans la
description sans smartphone que je
trouve vraiment vraiment vraiment
intéressant je trouve que wayne plus a
fait un excellent boulot sur la version
pro de son mois de plus 7
le smartphone est bien l'écran est bien
l'audio et bien la performance est bien
l'autonomie est bien le
si elle est bien il est bien il est un
peu lourd ça c'est une évidence mais à
côté de ça je trouve qu'il ya vraiment
de très très belles finitions la couleur
est très sympa je note pas les
smartphones mais si je vais lui mettre
une note
je pense qu'il aurait franchement une
excellente note je sais pas vous ce que
vous avancez comment vous trouvez
est ce que vous aimez les produits
douane plus est ce que vous trouvez que
c'est un beau produit qu'est ce que vous
pensez du fait quoi de plus nous propose
deux produits dans ce premier semestre
2010 9 points de plus cette pro est loin
de plus celle dont je vous parle très
très très prochainement d'ailleurs j'ai
tout de suite à vous abonner comme ça
vous saurez tout dites moi comment vous
le trouvez ce que vous en pensez
est ce que vous pourriez vous laisser
tenter est ce que vous allez succomber
et je donne les tarifs parce que je les
ai là vous pouvez le trouver en 6 il ya
de ram 128 go de stockage à 709 euros 8
gigas de ram 256 go de stockage à 759
house aura pas ce que j'ai appris par
coeur et la grosse version surboosté 12
ia brave 256 go de stockage à 829 euros
il est extrêmement bien placé au tarif
un pouvoir qui vient chercher des
smartphones comme le pétr en pro de
huawei comme le samsung galaxy s 10 16
10 plus je trouve vraiment bien placé
dites moi ce que vous en pensez comment
vous de prouver ce que vous allez
succomber oui non quoi comment vous ne
marquez tout ça en bas aux commentaires
et on reste connectés parce qu'on prend
très très très très très prochainement
devrait plus y avoir plein de choses
hyper intéressantes à dire à faire avoir
nous en parle mais si quelques jours à
bientôt ciao